sigh mark did you keep getting knocked
over yeah yeah some [ __ ] kept
throwing the dice right in my face
some jerk wad I don't honestly think I
was talking about you Wade but I'm glad
when you say something mean listen you
played Monopoly right
they have monopoly in Portugal right for
games in Europe property buying
monopolies capitalism you know about all
there it's not it sucks then you'll hate
it squish oh yeah the physics were just
a little off on those dice on my my
seven shitlords okay well wow you really
didn't have to be like that also for the
record the reason launched monopolies
it's binded to this account and I was
logged in on Lord minion 777 so why do
you have so many accounts you play
accounts all with thanks man just pass
over it man I went last last time and I
won so you saw your path now you know
what I'm saying the first shall be last
and the last shall be first I've never
heard of that quote what's that from
alright this nice job ship penis it's
from penis it's from deepest og biz Oh
Kathy says from a penis Vermont that's a
state in the US it's a great property oh
I can't hear you the goddamn game turn
the kid down it's down so low turn wait
you have a slider for systems turn it
down system flight basically make me
feel like I might throw up
mark explained this to you and some to
some extent right yeah there was a lot
of information that day but we went it's
none of it yeah listen cards before the
stream back at the start a little bit
200 dollars richer than you fools okay
all right this role I'm gonna go pay lik
see it really be lesser lesser yeah
welcome two pieces of wood that are not
a house all right can it be my turn now
please what are you gonna do you gonna
trade okay get that chance good as yours
I just pray and hope and hope and pray
and pray yes property yeah well you
didn't either so shut your mouth you
shut your mouth I win shitstorm I don't
want to win I didn't mute I don't want
to win he's just like ignoring us and
he's like I could use more milk not the
point but I appreciate you really went
for it I like milks good milk is good
but that is
all right okay all right hang on a
second you saw the path but you also set
up the game so I'm thinking here we go
[Laughter]
what am i doing to a different square I
don't know do anything the same three
places great all states this green
that's Allstate's stand are you in good
hands
not too watching we could be huh
but what never mind nothing okay all
right look at that stuff I got no extra
dice every time chance me chance me
daddy if I if I get southern what I'm
angry is that southern aggression is
that a thing yes it's already owned this
time
huh huh huh is this any good
oh it's for sale holy [ __ ] my mother
I'll buy it what what should it be
this is the joke that Waits mom it's
real hot or whatever a joke I mean it's
a joke because it used to be all right
way your mom's real [ __ ] wait I'll
give you what you want I think I feel
like you plant opened up some kind of
vortex and sucked us in my parents just
don't try wait stop try hey Lexi do you
want both utilities [ __ ] like eight
properties I've got one luxury - now
what you want to see we're basically the
same money and we're definitely on even
footing sad so with slow but it's pink
and it's a hat so it's you wear hats my
hat phase was in 2016
front flip you should it would cover up
my bald spot why would I would
[Laughter]
okay all right I don't appreciate you
buying my yellow property but it's not
yours dear sir three of those are owned
by three different people well that's a
crime that's not a crime why is it what
crime the crime against Wade manatee I
feel bad I interrupted Bob for that to
happen Bob continue please salvage this
commercial mine was not mine was not as
important as what happened that
superseded anything I've ever thought of
hey Lexi and why don't you go buy
another property what are the chances of
rolling a two now please yes does that
equal to man I'm so sorry mark and Bob
are gonna freak out eventually you're
never gonna be invited back no we're not
we're gonna freak out no one freaked out
I would never do such a thing mask you
about second mortgage what was that
guy's crazy prospector voice guy mark
oh damn it mark yeah yeah I'm sorry you
paid yourself you're your shoe I'm going
cars let's talk about this you can't
operate a car without a shoe whoa whoa
whoa you shouldn't have bought
that now Rick Grimes will have to do by
the way lick see and don't ask what a
bust means no none of us knows the bus
you get to play box means you get to
pick oh the man is the man don't make no
man chooses what man wants man I get to
move one two or three squares [ __ ] the
youngins
you know pay rent nearest railroad
nearest railroad nearest railroad or
that I'll take this for the applause
forever that was your turn you have no
property you shouldn't be celebrating
all right watch a move like this by a
real man nice roll boot boy thank you
booting car man oh look who's on my
property now slept on the good card yes
yes yes your advice was bad you should
feel bad yeah well they still paid me so
it's all good
all right oh the man was good and the
man is good no no no no good another
property for lick see it I just gotta
say this please stop trying to explain
what the man does we just don't want to
okay the man looks at you harshly he
stares through your soul and he sees if
your path is worthy and then he
determines where you go from then on out
or he takes you back in a dark alley and
he shanks you in the kidneys with like a
sharp knife
yeah that's what the man does gonna be
the man what's up against my boot well
it's the man and now I've got a third
property so suck my pain I still think
it's hilarious how proudly you tell that
story when it's not proud it's just I
figure it's okay okay how aggressively
you tell that story
I didn't describe the size uh-huh no
it's not the sizes time about the boner
itself was human quality of the boner
yes yeah but the size quality of the no
no no very different respect where did
you just go no that's not a [ __ ] is
baked so I get it what no never had a
baked boner no no where it's like just
so like it was lit and then cooked no
I've had a litter before but yeah is it
the oven boner the same thing no okay
tough crowd I went to shake that guy's
hand in awkward but he totally whipped
on the hand are you suggesting that you
went for a handshake and he mistook your
boner for the proper - Han understood
how he made the mistake he didn't just
reach out and grab your drunk though he
looked to you and he was like look at
the board I don't want to say that mark
just landed there but also there's a big
purple boot sitting there so see the
board bastard like you know yeah okay
six want that I want the property I
think that's owned already no it's not
see
yeah another property I was gonna get oh
hey look like saying oh my god it's been
a good game guys have any money so he's
not gonna be able to do anything with it
trade us anything color yeah we can get
a monopoly can we the way this game is
played is now that you have a monopoly
you have to give away the other color
car that you own yeah yeah really yeah
that's how it's a rule it's a rule you
don't have rules in Europe but in
America we play by a rule coasters we
have monopoly rules what you wanna see
no that's a bad move lady and you must
be new to the game this is not hey
everybody listen someone else should go
for a minute I gotta find my boner lots
of money with which to pay rent
no I think you're good on properties I
think I'm going
I forgot there's one more monopoly that
we can get guys so we just gotta work
together on this Brown oh go [ __ ] myself
again mmm masturbation is healthy at
least here we go hey thanks man
see now I just want to say but you said
before there would be some poor
sportsmanship and it would ruin the game
I feel like only one of us four people
is doing that right now and I think we
all know who I'm doing it moronically
thank you think you mean no he said what
he meant he meant what he said all right
well elephants memory 100% Dumbo 2019
did you just get the man again remember
when other people did things in monopoly
and not just listen you all wanted this
now you deal with the consequences no
you're not don't why are you doing with
your boner in my face of truth do you
baby that's what you get for not wanting
my boner
I got another where that come from came
from comes come came all right just shot
at the same time as us yes
hey there you go man just talk to me
myself and I I find myself hilarious
thank you all right I just want to ask
you funny it's just also a little bit
concerning are there any other
properties available for personal
besides this railroad everything and I
left and a reel and there's one read
that's on purchased I think the first
read Kentucky is not owned right now
there's two where's one railroad
available somewhere the third one the
second one oh this is not good position
for my next turn the poor Club hits you
in different ways I feel I feel you
right I feel that I really feel that why
is the cat's ass always up in the air
what does the POW cat stand with their
butts just money oh no we don't play
that rule whoa what is this
buying houses have any money the [ __ ] no
I know I know I'm just sticking yeah
this one right over there don't get that
red lick seeing dawn we're already down
I'm gonna get monopoly guy and never
mind
Hey all right fine now oh good my turn
how can this go hey wait you gotta get
that Brown okay all right what's he
gonna do oh yeah guess what guess who's
got 33% more properties now huh that's
pretty good okay I'm calling out for a
spirit bomb here lend me some of your
luck here just you know I don't I don't
like my oh you're gonna get that Brown
damn I am I
let's get this brown hair let's get this
man only bad now hmm yes yes man now the
man is not good now the man hates you
all right thanks Martin
screw you I've got the brown fine my
turn I'm gonna give you just do all my
properties you have you have the next
best chance to stand up to the man that
is liq see it okay we give you all my
money to balance this out no all right
technically Bob wins this if he pays all
2092 dollars would be a very stupid
thing for Bob to do so let's go I'm
desperate
what wait what'd you say I said I'm
desperate uh-huh okay all right
that's right one dollar at a time just
the way we wanted my strategies to the
repair guy a boater to you a boner to me
a boner to true rhymes with me rhymes
with you
Bob's your term Bob you do I'm busy I'm
going to destroy you
I will now it's not about who wins it's
about who stops this that sucks
[Laughter]
this is the dumbest thing we've done in
a history of dumb you've shut your mouth
we always surpass ourselves we don't
know our own limits which to go through
one dollar at a time ha ha and baby oh
my god well now we can't quit we're
really committed to this yeah we can win
that's never gonna end well for dollars
yeah all right wait-wait-wait-wait gets
my turn okay all right
wait what I will let you win it if you
give me two more bids two more bids yeah
what does that mean so we do we go
around the cycle two more times and then
you can have it I'll withdraw all right
deal mark okay all right sure
all right let's do this all right wait
it's yours yours wait take it coward
once again a representation of Wade
being the only douche bag you go
withdrawal mark I'll take it unless you
want it I'm debating I've got one you've
got one Oh whatever you can have it I
don't care
Bob I'll pay you five hundred and four
dollars for that I'm giving everything I
have to mark and I'm gonna curse you and
that you ever have all right monopoly
man don't touch me
wait didn't outplay us chat wage just a
liar okay and then you asked mark if he
consented and then you consented which
is exactly how you form an agreement
that would have been legally binding
good thing it's monopoly a monopoly
court you won't wait it's just trying to
be such a piece of [ __ ] that we're all
like fine we're never gonna play this
game I'm the one who's hated wait what
did you try to [ __ ] me I in turn [ __ ] to
you you're supposed to I could withdraw
here Bob I'll give you my green looser
yes you are because I just returned the
[ __ ] and you were the one whining
about it yes because you agree to do
something and then you took back your
word even though you clearly knew what
you were signing up for the reason
you're gonna lose this game it's me I
mean the real reason is lick seeing but
still thank God it's almost over we can
play something else not almost over with
his cards I will carry on the torch of
this game you have the Browns well yes
and three railroads yeah pretty good
right and a get-out-of-jail-free card
Marilee how do I I have to give you one
dollar is the trade
I have to give you $1 what is this now
it's nothing door let's see if you have
us all so [ __ ] right now only hope
this even if even with all of that he
just gave me I still don't think I can
you have enough to make it happen I
can't make monopolies I just can't I'm a
deck of these Browns so good you
couldn't see I believe in Mark Waid oh I
gotta go still yes the game still to
pick that one great I thought that was
Jail interesting idea
I fooled you all good huh alright well
watch this move I'm about to light it up
what is he gonna do to me only good
things well interesting move I guess
sure alright but wait for this it's
about to go down
oh yes yeah this this at the end game
now yeah I'm about to snap my finger
here we go yes power unbelievable power
okay alright I think that's all I can do
beware lick see and if I fall there I'm
screwed no well no actually that's
possible
nope what I am talking about
my lack of money is gonna screw me
that's not hey monopoly guy listen
[Laughter]
that's only 250 all right oh here we go
wait wait don't do it wait don't do it
please
oh you got the bus I can't see where I'm
going three marks six marks nine I can't
see I let's go no wait no nines no I
think actually yeah go for it fine I'll
go three okay well why wouldn't you go
through the all right oh because I like
to live dangerously I got a better
chance land on the turds from here to
other luxury probably roll higher you
know do man you sure do plus he's only
got one house what house isn't that bad
a couple hundred to like a hotel on
brown you know yeah you know what it is
it really is it really is man come on
come on wait oh no oh no another ten is
you just on the [ __ ] railroad ha but
it's to me yes give me your money
[Laughter]
Oh No guess who's coming back to win
this [ __ ] Oh Lex did have ten bucks I
guess Thanks this is gonna be a good one
I'm pretty sure oh I can either go that
place I can't see that place I can't see
you this is community [ __ ] what's wrong
with your
great all right well I'd buy that card
off you for like ten bucks no all right
you wanted to be in jail didn't you
didn't you want to be in jail it's all
set up so he's ready to win I don't know
man the fairway there yes no you know I
won't stop nickel and diming is really
gonna break you I'm gonna win all I
gotta do is nickel dime through every
single mortgage he can do and I win
that's all I gotta do well I'm just
gonna stay here till you guys mutually
self-destruct and then I'll win oh yeah
yeah whatever man yeah where's this Gus
oh no wait mark that's not too bad no
but it lets him it gives them enough to
it's not up for a bit so we can afford
to pay you and then do it like you won't
just put on right away he's good guy lik
see anything if you've got a goat and
you've got a cart comes down and see you
lick see it's art a way that looks like
your stratas paying off I'm just wait
don't freak out wait hold on sound wait
I don't have enough money no do it oh
yeah definitely save it up for a while a
couple years maybe you know if you
wanted the pro pro strats they're like
seeing you would mortgage all your other
properties in the flood well I'm not
paying $50 for this officer I did it
don't let me go hey oh I thought those
doubles good job
thanks man accomplish so far today I got
the buy for property that was gonna be
Snake Eyes for a second
one of the railroads cost me over five
no I think
that's probably it to go again right
into turd zone oh yeah yeah welcome to
turd town say my oh come on that's no
that's not fair that's well that's
didn't shuffle these [ __ ] chance
Martha Stewart prison I'm why my nerd
[ __ ] prison I wish I had money aren't
you in the same prison whole dollars Oh
mark why'd you let the monopoly man
happen you'll never get back Wade well
not with that attitude
this is good good like what's happening
right now
is there a thing that can happen with
the monopoly man where you go straight
over to church sound no-questions-asked
cuz I'd be interested in that straight
over to what town turnt down
there's not a card for that people go
turn town baby
boardwalk top 4 it's pronounced Illinois
ride not mark you rolled another
monopoly man are you for serious
look I'm not choosing to do this it
happens to me I have 14 bucks I don't
care about you
I just know you've made that abundantly
clear that monopoly you listen you could
make this better give me all your blue
no give me all your things like Bob did
it's your only chance
it's your only chance you're whispering
it's fully chance quick before it's too
late
the way
winning yes only that card what card
your guys freak guys you want it I'll
give it to you if you give me everything
you got
wink wink that feels like a fair trade
I'm gonna end my turn oh come on man no
balls on you no balls
whoa whoa whoa how about you give me all
your stuff I won't maybe I will maybe I
will all right yes karma Wade what are
you doing
now listen Wade no I dub there is only
one way
mark to make this happen wait don't
listen to you hold the hope of all
humanity in your hands doing play you're
the one true king I can't give you the
brown turn town but I must stay in turn
town it is my curse there will come a
time when you'll thank me for this
because you'll look inside yourself and
you'll see the Destiny that you need to
bla bla bla
no this is taking way longer than I
thought it would
yada-yada-yada great power great
responsibility holy why do I have so
much money why don't I so much money and
I can't do anything with it
how's your day wait all right listen you
have to accept this I'm just gonna put
it in that wasn't all of it yeah I gotta
go over um how do I get over to shift
okay give me one dollar okay except a
deal no no you don't know that man oh
yeah yeah there's a little more money
good thing I didn't get rid of it all so
you wouldn't have to bankrupt yourself I
see yeah yeah okay one day Kurd town
will be your world of hurt always okay
never mind what is happening that way I
need to think wait forcing me to trade
you know I can't say no to trades
[Laughter]
all right I see how this is going down
Oh God dollars Jesus Christ
wait listen this is the plan okay she's
gonna show up a little a little thing in
front of you in a few know in a few said
sure the repair guy a thing in front of
me too that's not no no boner pic no
look at what you're gonna have in trades
I love Pennsylvania my face baby you
know what oh you got a tit there we go
all right space space all right got a
counteroffer here look at those values
though I feel like you're really getting
back like seeing ear muffs mark pop do
you think this is a good deal yes oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no question
he's not interested he's from that's a
pretty good test yeah we're just gonna
roll all right well good move man you
can hit the button you want any other
time except when you actually want to
hit it great all right mark homie main
man uh-huh too safe here yeah thanks
buddy
why did I put all of our fate in his
hands it was basically the only option
don't worry about it true true true all
right yeah here we go
just roll I know I could pick either
place ooh don't don't give him the turds
I wasn't destined to be yours what I'm
not gonna I've literally not going to
mark please there was not this what
well this decision it all boils down to
this the one the only the Masters is six
six is free parking yeah you're good so
you definitely want fought [ __ ] thought
I had him there thought I had him there
mark thought I had him there what are
you talking to me I don't want to talk
to you all right all right fair enough
you got a cheer Mon weights weights our
only hope oh yeah okay yeah go away go
yeah I was good move yeah keep it up oh
great moves good thing yeah that's right
yeah
mark yeah uh-huh yeah what wait what
what you're my only hope
don't you [ __ ] die swear to God if
you do this yeah everything my
properties touches is your kingdom
I hate you no we're just gonna let's
just get that added here real quick so
that way I'm not [ __ ] it you know the
last second uh yeah you wouldn't want
yeah second you were in the middle of
your speech about responsibility
everything the light touches is through
my is your property and you're the
golden egg of the the goose and whatever
you do always remember that's it stars
button so that's all the money you're
getting for now wait wait wait wait wait
listen
wait it's out of my hands now mark I got
trade oh my
you are the one the light chose to be I
swear to god wait I'm gonna come and
kill you I'm gonna follow your gonna
wake up market fly we're gonna wake up
with keen ears kidney you are the one
who I I think that for every bacon there
is heaven to go with it so how could
they have filmed holloman Oh God
you know three hundred and seventy
dollars alright and the small price you
got to pay is a deal decline it I dare
you to climb this would you do it again
you don't know just because I don't want
to go through this [ __ ] again you
won't do it again
[Laughter]
thank you for calling my bluff because I
had a lot more to say just prepare
yourself prepare your neighbor's suite
cloak brand merch and here's three
hundred and twenty bucks because 4/20 is
just too much to handle for me right now
in the club as they say so there you go
deal if I go bankrupt what happens what
Mark and I did right there was called a
distraction mechanism to get likk seen
off his game we worked on that together
we practice this that's a lot of money
[Laughter]
there's more there's more wait
[Music]
wandered why not help it once I'll say
never wanna play Monopoly wait you're
not expecting this move what nope you
got yours I really want to see how these
options turn out I'm very invested in
this did I do this did I do this way
[Applause]
will go now let's really go now he won't
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know I'd play it again I'd play it
again look see what this is all said and
done which make a trade I still think
it's amazing that how much listed
actually legitimately just won that game
yeah I was ever having a chance yeah no
that was that was unfair you know in all
seriousness there was no way that we
could be you lose there was nothing we
could do I just said luck on the dice I
guess ya got one of every single
property and cinched it it was
incredible maneuver whoa he did not have
the browns mark you had a change mark my
golden light the darkness that envelops
the other dark now my deaf and real
quick piece ah
good gracious piece is it over is it
over much I appreciate everything you've
done the own
[Laughter]
[Music]
my buddy mark he sacrificed himself mine
my champion mark who should have had
this victory the man who put up with the
trades the great trade negotiations of
2019 here's we'll play again
[Music]